the home stretch one problem 18 this
diagram actually looks like something
that what I'm this little tool I'm using
is well-suited to draw let me try so let
me draw the one in the back first so I
can do different colors and everything
so I'll do the one in the back end
whoops and yellow and it looks something
like this goes like this and then switch
is over like that and then I'll draw the
next one this orange color and it looks
something I'll do anything I'll do it no
more drastic color so it does something
like this it goes like this crosses over
dips down then it goes like over again
and then finally and this this last one
it looks something like this crosses
over and it goes like that very pretty
now we switch to a smaller ok I'm going
to whiten over right and white in the
figure above so they say this is the
start and this is step one step one step
one this is step step two okay what is
this and the figure above three wires
are braided that is by starting in the
order ABC okay so this is a b c and then
oh the order changes to be right because
the yellow line is b a c and then we get
B see a right there's just the order of
the strings left to right or the braids
or the wires ok that is started with the
order ABC the outer left wire is brought
over wire be right this is brought over
wire be to the middle position forming
the order so in step 1 then the outer
right wire see this one how do I is
brought to the new middle position
showing step 2 and so on alternately
bringing each new left and each new
right wine in the middle at what
numbered step does the first does the
braid first repeat the original order a
be
see so what you do is you bring so you
first bring the left over the middle
then you bring the right over the middle
then you bring the left over the middle
then you bring the right over the middle
right so it's step 3 what do we have to
do so step one we brought the leftover
the middle so we got we went from ABC
you're essentially switch the left in
the middle and then step two you switch
the right in the middle so step three we
switch B and C again right because we
have two we're back on the left hand
side so you get c be a and then step 4
you're going to switch the right hand
side alright step three we switched we
switch these two now step 4 we're going
to switch these two so you get c a b
then in step 5 we're back switch on this
side so then you get a C B and then step
6 you're going to switch the right hand
side again so you get a B C so by step 6
we repeat so this choice D at the hard
part here as far as I'm concerned is
just kind of understanding the problem
in their diagram and then just seeing
the pattern that you're just switching
the letters but you know first you
switch the left and the middle letter
then you switch the right in the middle
letter then you switch the left in the
middle letter then you switch the right
in the middle either until you get back
to ABC next problem white I don't think
is colorful enough let me do magenta 19
in a set of 11 different numbers they're
different which of the following cannot
affect the value of the median cannot
affect the value of the median so lets
you know it's a set of 11 different
numbers they're different so let's let's
say it's 1 through 11 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 that's 11 different numbers and in
this case what's the median when we have
five on this side five and the median is
this that's the middle number right six
is middle number doubling each number
well if you double every number the
media is going to become 12 so that's
not right increasing each number by ten
once again if you increase all of these
numbers by 10 this number is going to be
16 so you'd have changed the median
increasing the smallest number only well
what if you increase the smallest number
two I don't know 12 so then you this 12
would go all the way on the other side
right and then the median would move to
seven because you would have to have
five below the median and five above the
median so you could increase that
smallest number but if you increase
increase it by a large enough month
amount it kind of goes into the greater
than the median column and then the
median the median that would have to
shift to the right try it out you know
right right out the list from 2 to 12
and then the median becomes 7 okay so we
know that choice B is not right choice
see increasing no no that was choice e
choice D decreasing the largest number
only decreasing the large somewhere well
the same argument can apply we could
take the 11 and decrease it down to I'm
going to decrease it 20 right you
decrease it to 0 then battle and you can
list them all out 0 through 10 and then
the median number will shift to 5 so
that will change it e increasing the
largest number only well I can tell you
that's the answer from deductive
reasoning but if we just take this 11
and we make it 1 billion does that
change the fact there are five numbers
larger than six and five numbers less
than 16 or 20 five numbers less than six
well no I can make it into a trillion I
continue to any number but the fact
remains is that I have the same amount
of numbers larger than six as I do below
six so choice II cannot affect the value
of the median e next problem oops invert
colors okay something for me to draw see
they have a quarter circle so I'll just
draw a big circle and you can I'll just
focus on a quarter of it
close enough and that looks like a
quarter of a circle they see they say
that Owen is a rectangle there too
fascinating so it's a rectangle in the
in this quarter circle so this rectangle
could look like this I know there's this
looks taller but I think this will do
and then I think I'm almost done think
i'm there i think i can and then they
shade in some stuff so if they shaded it
i will shade it a suitably tasteful
color okay so I've shaded what they have
shaded and now what are they saying
they're saying that this is this is our
see t be s a and then they tell us that
this is a that is a 90 degree angle and
then they tell us that this distance
from here to here from all the way the
top right so it's essentially the radius
of the circle is six right the radius of
the circle six and the figure above arc
SBT that's arc SBT is one quarter of a
circle with Center r and r 86 fair
enough if the length plus the width of
rectangle ABC r is eight so the length
plus the width so ABC are so this is the
width this is the length so L plus W is
equal to eight what is the perimeter of
the shaded region fascinating let's do
it step by step first we can just figure
out what this part of the perimeter is
and that's the easiest part right
because what's the perimeter of the
whole circle well it's the circumference
of the whole circle circumference is
equal to 2 pi r this is the whole circle
we're talking about so that's equal to 2
pi x 6 so that's equal to 12 pi is its
comforts of the whole circle so the
circumference of this arc of this piece
is going to be one-fourth of that
because it
one-fourth of the whole circle so it's
one-fourth of 12 pi so that's 3 pi now
what we need to be able to figure out as
Alan W cos if we can figure out ln w we
can figure out everything else about
about this circle and actually I'm going
to continue this problem in the next
video because I think it might get
involved and I don't want you to get too
confused I'll see you in the next video